how can we simulate the motion of fluids
and smoke if we had a block of plastic
in our computer program and we would add
the laws of physics that control the
motion of fluids it would immediately
start behaving like water
in these simulations were mostly
interested in the velocity and the
pressure of the fluid how these
quantities exactly change in time this
we need to compute in every point in
space which would take an infinite
amount of resources what we usually do
is we try to compute them math
everywhere but in many different places
and we try to guess these quantities
between these points by discussing a lot
of information is lost and it still
takes a lot of resources for a really
detailed simulation it is not uncommon
that one has to wait four days to get
only a few seconds of video footage and
this is where wavelet turbulence comes
into play we know exactly what
frequencies are lost and where they are
lost and this technique enables us to
synthesize this information and add it
back very cheaply this way one can get
really detailed simulations at a very
reasonable cost here are some examples
of smoke simulations with and without
wavelet turbulence it really makes a
great difference it is no accident that
the technique won a technical Oscar
Award among many other systems it is
implemented in blender so anyone can
give it a try make sure to do so because
it's lots of fun the paper and the
supplementary video is also available in
the description box this is an amazing
paper easily one of my favorites so if
you know some math make sure to take a
look and if you don't just enjoy the
footage thank you for watching and see
you next time